hello everyone and welcome to the third
leg of the feeder Grand Prix 2019 this
one is played in Hamburg in in Germany
at Saqqara Nakamura versus Veselin
Topalov I thought it was an interesting
game to show sorry about the e4 already
being on the board and sorry about that
now as usual in defeated Grand Prix
players are fighting for one of the two
spots in the candidates tournament that
will be held in 2020 so a lot is
underlined here and in the previous leg
of the feeder Graham dream that was held
in Riga Veselin Topalov eliminated
Hikaru Nakamura from the from the Grand
Prix 200 classical games would run then
at Apollo 1 their rapid game and then
the second rapid game was drawn so he
was able to eliminate him and definitely
Nakamura would enjoy getting back the
power here so without further ado let's
check it out and just a fun fact for
those of you who may be interested there
are two bids now for the 2020 World
Chess Championship match that was placed
by the United Arab Emirates and also by
Argentina
so the broaches championship match will
be held in one of those two places I
don't know if it automatically goes to
the highest bidder I remember in the
well I don't remember but I know that
for example during the negotiations when
the Fisher was about to play the World
Championship match first they asked the
humans passkey do they agree on the
venue and only they didn't agree then
for example I fear they would decide
instead instead of them but I don't know
if it goes automatically to the highest
bidder so I only know that for now it's
the United Arab Emirates and Argentina
if I know more I will tell you and if
some of you know more also do share in
the comments so that being said let's
check out the game Nakamura with the
white pieces opens with E 4 we have E 5
9 2 3 nights the c6 and Bishop to b5 we
have the rule opus is on the board with
Knight to f6 the Berlin defence D 3 and
Bishop to c5 d the alpha0 variation of
the Berlin
as a lot of nice games were played in
this variation the shop captures on c6
we have D captures in c6 nml h3 now we
have nine back to b7 and here a lot of
moves have been played here a castle has
been played here Knight the c3 has been
played here nice tonight B t2 has been
played here the Queen - E - was played
here Bishop to e3 was played here but
Bishop to g5 the MU nakamura plays is a
new move in the position and it is
already as a most seven that we have a
completely new game so if if it's a new
move why if it's a good move why wasn't
it played before
well the pull of pushes the bishop back
with f6 with Bishop back the e3 and now
Bishop captures on e3 with F captures on
e3 and now Queen to e7 so basically it's
the same as if for example white went
and Bishop to e3 first black just
captured and then after the trade black
decided to play f6 for some reason so by
that logic it should be good for white
unless f6 is actually a useful move in
this position and it would seem that yes
in this position f6 is a useful move so
nice the c3 by nakamura continue in
development with b6 the Paula wants to
develop the lights prohibition by
finicky rowing him we have castles by
Nakamura and the bishop to b7 at some
point to power will push c5 and you know
unleash the bishop with nice the h4 by
Nakamura kind of trying to bathe the g5
although very unlikely as this would
give a permanent f5 outpost a Nakamura's
night so a topo just plays g6 takes away
the f5 Square from from the night and
prepares f5 at some point with Queen e1
by Nakamura and now a queenside castle
by top off we have a three now preparing
to expand on the Queen side is to
Paulino Castle queenside and came to b8
just a nice prophylactic move with b4 by
Nakamura in the now c5 finally opening
up the light square bishop with Knight
to a4 putting more pressure here on the
c5 pawn also preparing to expand with c4
and the bishop the c6 the pulse says go
back with the night and here Nakamura
plays Knight back to b2 and hear it
well the night was of course more useful
on c3 as it controlled the d5 square and
it might be hard to develop your game
with one eye being unbe - and one night
being on the rim or maybe it won't we'll
see what happens
rook h the g8 top on our place is this
rockin G the other rook is coming to f8
so from there the two rooks will be very
strong when you start pushing the G and
the F pawn rook to d1 by Nakamura and
now rook D to f8 as planned and here c4
and now you can see that White's
position is in fact is in fact ok but it
would be a rather it would be ok if this
night was in c3 for example and if the
other night maybe was on f3 okay here it
kind of controls the f5 square but not
really there's not all that much you can
do to prevent it but if the knight was
on c3 you control the d5 squared that's
a good square for the knight on B -
you're gonna have to waste a move for
example bring this rope over here bring
the knight here bring the Knight to c3
to introduce the knight back into the
game okay top owl realizes that and he
says f5 let's start our attack on the
Kings side with b5 by Nakamura first
Bishop to b7 and now he captures on f5
and there is a double attack on d4 pawn
so you kind of have to react to this f5
move so it captures an f5 wheel G
captures on f5 now opening up the G file
for for this rook and the knight is now
also useful there as it guards the g2
pawn so we have looked to d2 now not
only adding another defender to the g2
pawn but also freeing the d1 square for
this Knights to get back into the game
we have Queen to g5 by Topalov now with
a triple attack on the g2 pawn and now
efore nakamura decides it's time to
close this beautiful diagonal from this
bishop F captures on e4 now nakamura
trades a pair of rooks rook captures now
not rookie actress you want your well
pressure on the G file to remain so
Knight captures and also you want this
night to come to a 6 from there both of
these very nice out costs d4 and f4 will
be available to you so the characters on
e4 now this diagonal is closed and now
Knight to e6 and now probably going too
deep d4 or f4
depending on what white place saw
tonight back to f3 kicking the Queen
back also keeping an eye on the e5 pawn
and now Queen to h5 already with a
threat of just Queen captures Knight as
you will not be able to capture back due
to the pin along the G file King to h2
Nakamura now gets this threat out of the
way and now tonight's the d4 just adding
another attacker here so already there
are some dangers here if for example
Nakamura made a silly move just rook
captures and g2 wins the game you will
not be able to capture if King g2 well
even if rubgy to didn't just Knight
captures here it Forks the king and the
Queen so you lose the game like that and
if you capture with the king it's just
Queen captures you move the king and
then just Bishop captures on e4
that's pretty much it you're gonna come
to h1 and if you block this with rook h2
just Queen a4 and now there is no
defense against Knight to f3 with a
monster fork so after this night the d4
move we have Queen to III and here we
have a very exciting moment it's it's
not an easy position of course it's a
very tricky position where the pull of
played a certain move I will not say
which move this is but feel free to
pause the video and try to find the best
move for black here and when you're
thinking of the movie think think of
capablanca it will help you well I give
you a couple of seconds so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations and finding such a such
a beautiful move and for those of you
who just want to enjoy a show to polish
up the c8 it introduces another attacker
into the game but there was an even
stronger a quieter move well it's a
pretty loud quiet move its roof to g4
this is just this is just insane as you
cannot capture of course but the point
is rook captures on e4 is a huge threat
and there is no way for white to defend
this that's white is helpless here just
rook captures on e4 on the next move
then you eliminate this pawn which
creates a passed pawn for yourself this
becomes a passed pawn you capture it you
move the rook to f4 and you start
pushing the the past a pawn so that's
that's the way to go and you don't get
the trade night for rook
because for example Queen captures this
comes with checks we don't have time to
pick up the rook
so really rook rook to g4 just just a
beautiful move it top all of missus it
probably because he's not the kind of
guy that goes after pawns but rather he
introduces another attacker into the
game already with a pretty big threat
Bishop captures on h3 I could already
create a lot of problems for for
Nakamura
so Nakamura gets the knight out of the
way night Stewie one not allowing in any
sacrifices and also adds another
defender to the G to pawn with Queen to
g6 now shifting attention to the e4 pawn
and also at some point at Apollo wants
to push h5h forth to really grab hold of
the g3 square so night e to d3 trying to
get to the Knights back into the game
sorry night etude III the this Knight
comes to III now preparing to bring the
Knights into the game also attacking the
e5 pawn and now rook to e8 for the
moment the power of defense the pond
with Knights to d1 now Rema nuvaring
with the night and now Queen back to g8
now attacking the c4 pawn so here just
Knight three to be two defending the c4
pawn and now Bishop to e6 adding yet
another attacker to the pawn so here at
Apollo didn't really find a way to break
through the defenses on the King side
and now he has to go for for the pawn
with Queen to d3 adding another defender
to the pawn and now rook to d8 aligning
the rook with with the Queen here so
Queen to C 3 of course Nakamura doesn't
like that and now h5 the idea is h4 at
some point you want to bring your rook
over here and then place your look on g3
so rook the f2 by Nakamura hoping that
if the rook ever and the Queen leave the
final rank you might have some ideas
with maybe rook to f8 and if you can get
this point all the way to a6 could be
one of the ideas you have for a
counter-attack
so h4 by top olive and now a four we
have Queen to g6 now again a going after
the pawn on e4 and again Nakamura
defends at Queen to e3
rook the g8 and now comes King to h1 not
allowing
Queen to g3 check you will be unable to
trade because this captures with the
cherry then you lose the rook
so Kings to h1 just not allowing any
chicks and now Queen to h5 preparing to
bring the rook over to g3 and here a5
and here Topol should go for rook to g3
even allow rook to f8 check but after
Bishop to see it you kinda have to see
that after Queen to f2 which threatens
the bishop captures to just bring the
Queen all the way out there you can just
capture here and white is not in time to
push a six but top Allah decides that
he's just gonna get to the King over to
a much safer Square as he doesn't want
to deal with this on the Queen side so
Queen back the e1 now preparing Queen to
f1 to double rooks on the F file not
rooks but to create a Queen rook battery
on the F file and only now rook the g3
by top off with Queen to f1 now
preparing to bring the rook over to f8
with check so King to d7 just getting to
a nice safe or safer Square and now
Knight the d3 which seems odd as it
gives up the c4 pawn but even if you try
something like Knight to a4 you still
lose the c4 pawn because if Queen
characters then Queen captures the
knight on d1 which check the Queen is
guarding the night here so we have
Knights to d3 with the idea that if a
Bishop captures then Knight captures
with Czech might pick up the bishop so
tapaa love doesn't want to go into this
it's a very tricky line Bishop captures
Knight captures with Czech Queen
captures and Queen captures on c4 Queen
captures on e4 and now Queen to f7 check
and now you have to calculate it after
King d6 rook f6 check Knight blocks and
that you are actually fine after Queen
f8 okay the knight is pin so you cannot
move just king - not the d5 but the e5
and not enough you escape everything and
you are better of course but it's it's a
lot of calculation and if it's not
necessary just you know play King to e7
and now you don't have to calculate all
that much so Knight 1 back to be to
keeping an eye on the c4 pawn and here
look back to g8
we have a 6 now and now comes Queen to
g5 again doubling up on the chief
and the Queen to g1 by Nakamura so here
it you know it's when I saw this
position I thought well okay Bishop
captures on h3 is obvious but obviously
there's something wrong with it as T'Pol
didn't play it and indeed if Bishop
captures on h3 you can go Queen here now
just attack the bishop and also the e5
point is attacked twice so here you
would have you would just have to go
back and allow Queen captures on e5 so
that's what what's wrong with Bishop
captures on h3 so here at the Paul wins
c6 he wants to break this punch in here
the idea is just to capture and then
capture back with the night so Nakamura
trades on c6 with Knight captures and
not look back to f1 and here Queen to g3
again with the idea of now just
capturing here and after upon captures
you capture with the Queen you deliver
check and after the White Queen blocks
you're just gonna pick up the rook on f1
so a pretty straightforward plan and
Nakamura prevents it with Queen to f2
and then now again feel free to pause
the video what do you play here well I
give you a couple of seconds of course
for those of you who were able to find
it congratulations on finding such a you
know elusive tactic and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
it's Bishop captures on h3 again point
is after the Queen is captured and the
pawn is captured the bishop cannot be
taken so you just grabbed a clean pawn
and now you just have a winning
advantage I mean a much better position
which you should convert with proper
play because if you capture then just
check and you lose the rook
however the Polo did not play Bishop
captures on h3 Topalov saw that there
are weak pawns on the on the Queen side
that night if I will just pick up the c4
pawn so he just traded Queens we have 90
capture screen and now just rook to d8
preparing to bring the rook to d2 which
will be a super active rook so nakamura
already prepares how he's going to
exchange it with Knight F 2 d1 okay top
Allah brings the rook into the game and
now look to f2 you have to prevent it
otherwise it's it's too active a rook
so rook captures Knight captures and now
probably the idea what Apollo did not
search so far to find the other idea as
he saw night if I've just picks up the
c4 point in that that will be enough
so King h2 by Nakamura and now Knight
captures on c4
we have Knight to a4 of course avoiding
further trades now there are some plans
for example that this night can capture
on b6 and after pawn recaptures you can
after this night polls of course at the
moment you're regarding the b61 but you
should bring your king closer just you
know take care of all of whites idea so
night back to c3
King to c6 and now g3 we have H captors
and g3 King captures now Nakamura also
created a passed pawn and now b-52 power
now starts pushing his path bone so here
the pollo is up a pawn but also his
position is just better
so Knight the d3 in going after a d5
pawn if the knight moves that is and now
just before pushing the knight back with
night stay for with a double attack here
but topple doesn't care he says if you
capture that I'm just gonna pull the
pawn and that's it
so h4 and Nakamura starts pushing his
own past pawn but Bishop to f7 not
allowing it kingi for preparing to push
further now bishop g6 going after the e4
pawn now we have Knight back to c3 and
here just B to the B to point protected
so it's not a problem and here Nakamura
is out of any good ideas he goes back
with the king king d6 now again adding
another defender to the pawn here now
the knight can move so Knights the b5
check here Nakamura tries to take care
of the a7 pawn and maybe create some
chances here but the power of calculates
precisely king D 7
we have Knight captures and b2 now as
typologies threatening to promote it
Knight captures and now Knight captures
an a7 and here topologist play Bishop to
h5 check and it was in this position
unmoved 66 that he call Nakamura
resigned the game so it seems that he he
really doesn't do well against the pole
of but you know yeah you always have
someone who who you want to play against
who don't want to play against or maybe
it's just you know chance that he lost
twice to him in the feed a Grand Prix
even though like I said previous to
class claims were drawn in the Rig Veda
grand prix here in Hamburg
now Topol takes a win in the classical
time section so tomorrow
has to went back if he wants to go into
the rapids otherwise he is again
eliminated by T'Pol from the feeder
Grand Prix here you just don't have any
chances it's just too easy for the king
to control the past pawn whatever you do
King g3 just bishop here you could pick
up the pawn here it's really if you got
the pond and just you can deliver check
whatever black whatever white plays you
can just go after this pawn and the King
will like I said very easily control
this pawn so Nakamura of course resigned
and an excellent win for Veselin Topalov
in round one of the feeder Grand Prix in
Hamburg
so he's I don't know how he is in total
points but I don't I don't think he's at
the top for the candidate spot but you
know if he does extremely well it of
course is possible he is one step closer
to that candidates tournament and you
know a candidates tournament with the
polo in it is always you know a cheerful
event so that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank publi
Mohan Martin Walters and Krishna Serena
for a contribution to my channel thank
you I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see soon
continuing the coverage of the feeder
Grand Prix as I will be covering it up
until Friday on Friday I have to I will
be going to Germany for a few days not
in Hamburg I'm going to but Piermont but
maybe just maybe I will visit the feeder
Grand Prix in Hamburg if I manage at the
time so we'll see how it goes and if any
of you are maybe from there maybe we can
grab a beer or you know just chill or
something like that but I will keep you
informed but yeah that's like I said the
game I do hope you enjoyed it and yeah I
will see you soon
thank you